[Applaudissements]
tu m'a dit viens faisons le sens où les
bleus ce froid je vous ai fumé trop
d'erreurs sans allumer n'co et bob tahri
du piège entre nous ça n'a duré qu'un
grain de sable est ce que tes rires des
larmes tueur à présent la vie en bleu je
dire tu m'aimes on s'aime jamais éprouvé
ses patrons
peux tu dire entre les lignes ainsi je
te font plus on ne trouve pas
quand on se la sont
on avait envie
[Musique]
m
ce kit
[Applaudissements]
du
m
10h31 thiès je connais très bien c'est
après que ça une odeur de gazoline ton à
lumino biencourt quoi ta peau le faire
vibrer et toute la dream est jeté
au regard des rendez vous manqués un
jour on se pour conclure à la diva
jean duverger l'éclair je tiens tu fais
aussi même jamais aimé
pourquoi je vais
petit lait entre les lignes si j'étais
ne trouvant plus de
comme on sait
en vue en vie
[Musique]
voilà comment
là
ce qu'ils étaient
[Applaudissements]
là
tabitha but
comment
[Applaudissements]
des légendes
merci à ce fabuleux quand même parce que
c'est énorme qu'ils soient là merci
d'être là danis et dany merci trois
choix merci merci beaucoup merci
lucioles bières cidres dixon est avec
nous a mijoté